contradiction maladresse ou simple
repositionnement on en parle tout de
suite avec mes collègues vidal directeur
de putsch médias bonjour à vous merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors pour le port du masque la
posture du gouvernement que kankan
penser justement il n'y a pas vraiment
de discours oui il n'ya pas plus qu'il
n'ya pas de discours tout simplement au
mieux des incantations au pire envie de
dire des entourloupes et cela en fait où
la profonde les corps car tant que père
et qui donnait tant à kita des tarabates
dans les médias depuis quelques jours et
on voit que l'écran du portable on vous
donnait là le 19 mars il ya sept
allemands un gars une fête ne faut pas
demain si ce n'est pour l'espagnol car
ce malade est aujourd'hui marche arrière
il nous dit qu'il a toujours été
favorable au port du masque donc là
concrètement minutes en droit de se
poser des questions sur je le répète
cette impéritie et on va dire mais
allons plus loin sur l'amateurisme
aujourd'hui de sa tutrice de parler
fictifs et 18 sont censés l'amener là
combat qu'on voit un peu la manière dont
la crise est gérée dans les autres pays
européens
qu'est ce qu'il faut en conclure
justement par rapport à ce qui se passe
en france mais à la réalité vous l'avez
vu c'est que chacun fait comme il peut
les premiers états européens se sont
fermées les prélèvements se sont fermées
les anecdotes attendre et puis
maintenant c'est était affligeant ce
sont les régions qui sont enfin et les
mairies on l'a vu à toulouse dans la
pierre barthère a dû à bordeaux ronde à
bülach la région paca ils sont en train
de commander des masques eux mêmes
finalement c'est chacun pour chacun pour
soi il s'est même pas au niveau de
l'union européenne sont au niveau des
régions françaises donc les pompes
on me disait en son temps lors des
régions ça déjà existé sarthe et le
moyen âge et c'était pas de raison pour
moi de façon assez incroyable
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que chacun est
libre à lui même chacun c'est par la
bière email dû aller plus loin on se
fait la guerre des maths pour seul et
est entre continents on se l'est fait
entre payement d'une y aura tellement
j'aime beaucoup l'idée pays membres de
l'union européenne
et maintenant ça fait enfants région en
scène tient absolument c'est absolument
un scandale aujourd'hui lors de matches
il vous l'avez dit
effectivement on a eu ce matin comme
vous devez bien après que le 4 mai nous
pourrions avoir des matches donc j'ai vu
quelques tirs des panthères mais en fait
on lit la déclaration
daniel manière une hache et elle dit
l'état kosovar de terreau matelas des
citoyens des costumes par les canaux de
distribution les mieux adaptés mais on
parle a fait part après
d'expérimentation donc finalement tous
les français l'europe allemagne 4e mais
on n'est encore sûr de l'expérimentation
qui est toujours présupposés au
conditionnel ou au futur et je pense que
cette situation commence à s'aggraver et
on voit que nouvelle fois de la
cité-etat s'affranchit pas toujours là
de plus en plus haut alors ça rentre
dans le cadre du des consignes mans en
tout cas on s'y prépare sur la stratégie
justement gouvernementale on a parlé de
déconfinement progressif là aussi il ya
eu beaucoup de messages ont faut
comprendre aussi qu'on devait sauter
confie dé manière progressive et hier
emmanuel macron a déclaré qui aurait pas
de déconfinement par région le message
il est un peu floue en tout cas on en a
l'impression
qu'est ce qu'il faudra retenir après
cette crise justement sur les
conséquences de cette pandémie sur la
suite justement du mandat présidentiel
par exemple on a parlé des masques
ça peut faire penser aussi un masque
gate bien sûr effectivement mais hier
taille obtient donc préparé des
respirateurs les fameuses limite tu
attends respirateur sont arrivés qui
sont pas adaptés à la traitement
réalisation dépassée du coït donc
finalement c'est quoi ces l'impéritie
des tasses et de désarmement de l'état
le désarmement sanitaires aujourd'hui
notre service public on se rend compte
qu'ils m'aiment bien le maquereau dans
chercher encore une fois suite au procès
de l'europe à la souveraineté la fameuse
souveraineté européenne qu'ils essaient
péniblement de définir comme il ne peut
en tout cas pas d'accord par consensus
cette histoire-là des masques cette
histoire-là du coc vite il parla du
délabrement absolue des services
sanitaires de la france et je pense
devra reposer la question de la
mondialisation d'autres questions de
l'attachement à l'union européenne qu'on
a montré on a vu qu'elle était incapable
de curé l'abbé center aujourd'hui
personne est absolument d'accord sur le
plan de relance a adopté les pays du sud
vous l'avez lu le suit pas à l'allemagne
et il ya longtemps
avant mais concrètement aujourd'hui tant
qu'on continuera à rester dans ce dans
ce goût be good bye européen où on en
appelle toujours plus d'europe plus
d'europe d'europe la réalité qu'on a vu
que les pays n'ont eu que 2 stand de se
refermer sur base de ce fait de compter
sur un même finalement pas une crise
comme ça on s'est rendu compte que ce
n'est pas protégé son peuple encore
petit peu l'état soit suffisamment armé
de façon certes pas tant le mcg il avait
raison bien entendu niera toute la
question à ceux proposés de services
publics et de l'état en tant que
métaphore parce que l'état ne peut être
que portent nos yeux de l'état si l'état
n'est pas fort et qui montrent des ses
bêtes on le voit avec des affaires on
s'en rend bien compte un moment donné un
but at elle été la plateau kouwe
troubles et autres donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir se poser
très septembre la question de notre
appartenance à l'union européenne alors
qu'emmanuel manière continue à parler
souveraineté européenne ce avait choisi
de toujours plus loin de pouvoir y a pas
assez d'europe il ça a été un vrai
problème sur trois que cette petite
corne à dire une copie dit a produit
mais avec dernière au grand jour d'été
fan absolu de notre état qu elle était
dictée de 30 ans des faits européens et
des politiques d'austérité absolument
gigantesques qui ont donc conduit dans
le mur finalement état vraiment je pense
que c est dans le même temps dans le
même temps c'est vrai que ce virus il
est imprévisible finalement ne sait pas
grand chose sur ce virus
ce n'est pas facile pour le gouvernement
justement l'impression qu'ils naviguent
à vue c'est pas facile de prendre des
décisions dans ce contexte la partie la
réponse on peut le voir comme ça
effectivement les rues de tarifs bon on
est on arrive on essaie d parce qu'on
peut mais concrètement une nouvelle fois
j'imagine que nous avons nous avons des
relations et la chine en bois elle plus
qu'un certain temps aujourd'hui on a vu
des cars à sa manette + 1 stendhal s'il
vient de rendre x et jean répondre à la
sortie de la petite giulia sortie dans
les airs le plus rapidement possible
mais une nouvelle fois si on n'avait pas
été désarmés comme on l'a été deux
personnalités à regarder production de
santé les soignants qui ont manifesté au
raf est encorte mêmes stations petit
côté et comment fortement arrive tenait
aujourd'hui à l'érection de ces mêmes
humains on se rend compte du bien fondé
bien fait des sites santé et aussi je
veux en parler des filets jeunes et la
prospérité en fin de quart des pays
parce que c'est un outil qui leur seront
utiles des soignants swan et la france
périphérique fait pour l'emporter dans
finalement ya tellement de paille et on
a été désarmé et on a pris on aurait pu
disant qu'on aurait pu amortir la crise
si on avait moins et de la grande de
théorie par rapport à l'union européenne
ça c'est extrêmement important et je
n'avais pas qu'il est et européens en
permanence et qu'on avait vraiment
reposé sur un état fort avec avec titeuf
soutien voilà merci beaucoup à nicolas
vidal un jardin vous êtes directeur de
putsch médias merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france